[Music]
sela is with us in vancouver washington
hi selah how are you
hi dave thanks for answering my call
sure what's up
hey um so i am 24 years old i'm married
i just had we just had our first baby
he's 10 months old now um
congratulations and
thank you
it's been fun um inexpensive
so
so my question is um here in vancouver
washington as you guys probably know the
cost of living here is astronomical a
decent house in a decent neighborhood is
anywhere from and this is a minimum of
325 350 but you know if you're going to
get a sizable house if we want to have
another baby and have a three bedroom
it'd be like 400 000
and so the 20 down payment is very a
very large amount and
i'm just wondering for people my age
especially the millennial and gen z
generation
um the option of zero down
so uh
we have sixteen thousand in our savings
account um we've got two thousand in
stocks we're going to have forty
thousand by august of this next year and
um but we're just wondering if we should
just do zero down versus doing all of
the
versus wiping it out if that makes sense
well zero down i would not buy a house
that means you're it means you're if you
don't have any money you shouldn't buy a
house
that's a bad plan you're going to get
yourself in a pinch
so you need an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses and you're
debt free before you start talking about
buying
um on a first time home buy i don't
think we don't tell people you have to
put down 20
it's just preferable because if you
don't you're going to have pmi private
mortgage insurance which is going to run
you about 75 to 100
per 100 000 borrowed per month
so it turns out to be a lot of money
going to an insurance program that pays
them
the mortgage company in the event you
get foreclosed on that also applies to
first-time home buyers
and home buyer programs
so there are no first-time home buyer
programs that don't have some kind of
mortgage insurance backing on them
and so it gets to be very very expensive
and the you know the whole premise of a
first-time homebuyer program is that
first-time home buyers don't do not have
any money and they need to buy a house
anyway well that's a dumb butt idea
and so i'd stay away from those programs
uh they're really not a big blessing uh
you know and if you don't put down
twenty percent i'm okay with that but
put it on a 15-year fixed where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay
and let me tell you what
if you think vancouver washington is an
area you cannot afford to live in under
those guidelines then that means
vancouver washington is an area you
can't afford to live in
you may not be able to afford to live in
silicon valley either or in
manhattan island very very expensive
real estate there's a lot of areas
people cannot afford to live in because
they don't make enough money to live
there
i don't think that's true in your case i
think you're out there looking around at
houses and you just saw something you
liked and then you started crafting this
narrative in your mind that you can't
afford that the only houses that you can
afford are are the only ones you like
are the ones that all they have and
that's just not true
so i think you take your time you
continue to learn the real estate market
you get a good down payment in place
it does not have to be 20 20 down but it
does need to be
a 15-year fixed and where the payment is
no more than a fourth of your take-home
pay if you don't do that you're going to
slow
your wealth building dramatically
because you use the wrong set of
assumptions to handle your money it's
going to put you in a pinch
yeah the other thing i would just
encourage you to think about is even if
you want to have more children in the
future you can look at getting a larger
home when you have more cash in the
future you don't have to have your first
home
be the house with all the bedrooms and
the location you want start a little bit
further out of town maybe smaller less
bedrooms and then in a few years that
home value has gone up if you want to
sell and you've got more cash saved
you'll have more options you don't have
to do it all right now you don't have to
rush it